uh so who all do you have on this new
album you say you got g herbo kiss
i got herbo i got kiss i got asian doll
i got benny the butcher
i got dotted a dealer
[Music]
8-zip from boston and why drizzle from
boston you put out a video asian dog
right yeah i saw that that's kind of a
random collab yeah yeah yeah didn't see
that one coming yeah we met we met in a
crazy way we met um
we met in a strip club and i was
literally about to say i bet you better
at a strip club oh yeah you know that
we met in a strip club in atlanta
and um
and and and i was i was with my people
who knew her and we left out
and i had the culling in the the
the rose truck or whatever and we all
jumped in the rose truck and we were
going to go to the next spot and then
shots just started going off
like little machine gun fire and [ __ ]
and um and i'm bent i'm smacked you know
what i'm saying and my man is like yo
get down get out the car get down
but i feel like the shots aren't too
close to me type [ __ ] so i just i get
out the car or whatever
i get down but like before i do that
like i just look in the passenger side
and like asian dogs just in the
passenger side like fixing her makeup in
the mirror unfazed while the shots are
going off
look i'm like
[ __ ] ends
i'm like yo you doing your makeup while
the shots was going off like man i'm
trying to get to my next destination
some [ __ ] like that like oh no she's
different and then we locked this since
then so yeah
yeah she did a freestyle for us a couple
years ago that was she was five solid
yeah it was good she's fine surprisingly